hello everyone
if you're watching this you're either a
student currently or have been one at
some point in your life and i'm
confident
that at one time or another you have
definitely felt disappointed or
frustrated or at the very least sleepy
while listening to a classroom lecture
perhaps you have tried to give voice to
your feelings only to be shot down by
questions like why can't you be more
focused in class why can't you be more
attentive why can't you be more serious
with your studies
and those types of questions may have
left you feeling even more frustrated
but what if we are asking all the wrong
questions
what if we are pointing our questions in
the wrong direction perhaps instead of
the students we should be asking
questions to the people who actually do
the teaching that is the teachers and
the professors the college professors
perhaps rethink re-evaluate and look
into the actual research that has been
done to transform teaching from a mere
tool to cover the syllabus to something
that can actually help the students
learn
and in this video we are going to do
exactly that through a conversation with
professor richard felder a professor
emeritus of chemical engineering in the
north carolina state university united
states professor felder is a pioneering
figure
in the field of research on education
on engineering education specifically
and he has also been a long time
practitioner of what he preaches
through a unique teaching style
that centers on students learning
accountants psychologists and physicians
who undergo years and years of
supervised training before being
actually allowed to practice on their
own
but not college professors if i put
everything on powerpoint slides and
flash them like this
during the class and i'll cover the book
will they learn anything no the only way
people learn in a meaningful way
is by doing things when students are
taught in this manner they learn more
they learn at a deeper level and they
get higher grades on the examinations
and if you do this i'll give you a
guarantee
your teaching is just going to start
getting better to many of you in
chemical engineering departments his
name may already be very familiar
because of the famous textbook felder's
elementary principles of chemical
processes next what follows is a
discussion with professor felder
hello professor felder a very warm
welcome to my small youtube channel uh a
big thanks for agreeing to be here it's
a pleasure for me to be here jivan thank
you thank you
so my first question has to do with a
little bit of history and i'm sure our
student audience will appreciate it
so
i've already mentioned your book your
famous book elementary principles of
chemical processes but we are not going
to discuss that we are going to discuss
teaching and learning
on which also you have written a book i
believe it was published in 2016
uh teaching and learning stem
so you have written at the very
beginning of your book
uh it would be unthinkable to allow
people to practice a skilled profession
without first being trained for it
especially if their mistakes could cause
harm to others
unless they are college faculty members
so to drive home this point you have
given the examples of numerous
professions accountants psychologists
and physicians who undergo years and
years of supervised training before
being actually allowed to practice on
their own
but not college professors
they get the job the college professor's
job based on the proficiency that they
show in research and then they are
expected
through some magic to turn that
proficiency in research into a
proficiency in teaching so my question
to you
is how do we end up in this situation
it's a weird weird situation but it is
what it is it's been that way ever since
i was a student
um
teachers
uh training for teaching in college
is just something that uh has never been
part of the preparation for the job as
far as i know now maybe before i was
born
um before research was an expectation of
faculty members at research universities
some training was provided but i'm
guessing no
i'm guessing that training and teaching
was never provided at the college level
maybe with some exceptions of
universities that take teaching very
seriously and possibly that don't have
strong research programs and so the
situation that we're in you wouldn't say
uh
you know good morning dr so-and-so we're
delighted to have you with us at this at
our university um
we expect you to
do a lot of good research and get grants
and funding and so forth and you're also
going to be teaching a couple of courses
there at your office good luck
and that's a
maybe an exaggerated version of how
short this uh
training is but it's not far off and so
the situation that we're in is that uh
without any
training in teaching the only guidance
we have
is how our teachers taught us
when we were college students
but nobody taught our teachers to teach
either and so it just perpetuates
through the decades and
and centuries
i don't really have a good answer to the
question of how did this happen
but the fact is that it happened and
it's unfortunate for students
um and the example that you gave before
you can imagine doing this to a surgeon
for instance uh telling you welcome to
our hospital we're delighted to have you
here um there's your office and uh good
luck
that would not end well
and in many cases
uh the same approach does not end well
at universities
yeah it sounds a little bit dramatic
when they put it this way but at least
for the sake of the students who often
wonder
why is it
sometimes so very bad
there's a reason we are not basically
trained for it
that yes i think that that plays a major
role in it
the other thing is there's no guarantees
either way
some teachers could give them
four years of training and teaching
and
because of a lack of communication
skills or a lack of interest in teaching
they may be primarily interested in
their research and that's really why
they went into the college professor
business
and so even with training they might not
be good and conversely
despite the lack of training
there are some absolutely superb
teachers
out there
most of us
who have been college students can point
to at least a few
teachers who were just absolutely
excellent they were wonderful
communicators they were clearly
interested in their students and in the
quality of their teaching and so even
without training they were naturally
gifted in it
but the majority i think of professors
would be
considerably better as teachers if they
were given some guidance before they
jumped into the profession
and that's a lot of what i've been
spending the last several decades of my
career on
is trying to persuade
college administrators
that
there are better ways of doing it and
that a lot is known about the learning
process and the things that help make
learning happen and the things that get
in the way and they're not
it's not rocket science many of these
techniques that make a big difference in
teaching
can be taught and can be learned
and that to me is the
rational way of approaching preparation
for this profession
thank you professor and uh thank you
especially for bringing up the point
that uh at some point or another in our
lives as faculty members
we were definitely influenced by some of
our own teachers
so maybe they they did not follow
anything special but just by their
enthusiasm just by their clear
communication
and even just by the interest which
always shows up uh even if they are not
trying uh if they're really interested
in teaching us it somehow shows
and we get influenced by that
so uh i think i mentioned this to you
over email before we started this
conversation that i was personally
really really influenced by one of our
teachers here at iit kharagpur and he is
one of the main reasons that i i decided
that okay this might be a job i i may do
one day so this was back in 2006 my
fourth semester of my undergraduate days
i thought that okay i could perhaps do
this job one day i very much like to do
this and i have ended up
doing that jivan you raise a really good
point
most of us are fortunate enough to be
able to point to those
handful of professors we had who were
really good clearly interested clearly
interested in us and our learning
and doing everything they possibly could
to facilitate that learning and that can
have a profound effect and and that's
one of the things that i love about this
profession
is we have the potential to really
interest
really
excite
our students and influence their
direction in life
and that's one of the reasons that i
would not consider
going into any profession other than
this one absolutely that potential for
influencing people
yes yes and uh and actually that is one
of my uh most philosophical motivations
for preparing this video that i i
imagine and i believe that somewhere out
there there is
a 20 year old kid who will be
uh heavily influenced and inspired by
this video and maybe similar videos to
this
and end up being much much better
teachers than i will ever be
the fact that you're doing this
that you're clearly as interested as you
are
in this whole topic
suggests to me that in
in the future at some time you may be
sitting where i'm sitting now
and being interviewed by uh somebody in
the generation after yours
thank you
okay so moving on it is absolutely great
that
we have had teachers who despite their
lack of teaching through their
enthusiasm have managed to influence us
have managed to enthuse us
but uh it doesn't change the fact that
a lot of research has actually gone into
teaching into engineering education
especially uh you have been a pioneering
figure in that so uh for the sake of our
audience who may not be at all aware of
what you have been doing over the past
few decades uh could you please give us
a
very very condensed uh like orders of
magnitude condensed overview of your
work i i know i mean this could go on
for hours and hours and probably days
so this is the most difficult question
but i request you if possible to
condense it to a few
all
sentences
that's as
great a challenge as i think i've ever
been presented with
but i'll
i'll give it my best shot
um
when you look at the literature on
teaching and learning
and the book that
my colleague rebecca brent and i wrote
and published in 2016
sort of puts together a lot of the
things that i learned
by reading previous literature and from
my own experience of trial and error of
finding out what seems to work and what
doesn't work
the
couple of the main points
that i learned and that i tried to put
in the book and in papers that i've
written
one is that
probably the least effective
method of teaching
and also common method of teaching is
straight lecturing
i get up and i talk at students for 50
or 75 minutes
and they sit there and they listen
and maybe
they might interrupt me uh to ask a
question
usually in a class that i'm teaching
there are two or three students who
routinely ask all the questions
but they can do that and most of the
students are sort of sitting there
passively
taking in information or not taking it
in as the case may be
and
that does not cause learning to happen
and there's tons of research backing
that up
people do not learn much if they learn
anything at all by sitting and listening
to somebody else tell them what they're
supposed to know
the only way people learn in a
meaningful way
is by doing things
so
i may talk for a little while on some
point of engineering in the course that
i'm teaching
and then instead of just continuing to
talk for the rest of the 50 minutes i
might give a short example of something
and then i might say all right to this
now you try it
and either i'll ask them to do something
for a short period of time
maybe two minutes maybe even less than
that all right i've just given you an
example of how to do a calculation
here's a similar problem i'm going to
give you two minutes see how far you can
go in getting it started
all right and sometimes i'll say do it
by yourself and sometimes i'll say turn
to a neighbor or two neighbors and i'll
give you two minutes see how far you can
go in doing this
and then i turn them loose for the two
minutes however long i want to give them
and then i'll stop them and i'll say
okay uh joe
how did you two begin this
susan
where would you go from here and i'm
getting them to tell me what they did
two things happen
when i do this
one of these short exercises and this
incidentally the the name for this
technique is active learning
it's getting students to do things for
themselves in class rather than just
listening to me the whole time
so some of these groups of let's say
groups of two that have been working on
this in the two minutes i give them do
it they figure it out how to do it
and if they do it they own it
they know how to do it because they did
it
other students will struggle for the two
minutes
and they won't
get it they didn't understand it
sufficiently to the point where they
could do it themselves
but
now they know this is something i need
to know how to do
and i don't know how to do it because
the two of us tried and we were not able
to do it in the two minutes
and so at this point hands will go up uh
professor i didn't understand you know
where that number came from when you
were doing this before
or i'm stuck i can't figure this out
right and uh
and at that point i will answer the
question
when those students leave
the two minutes of struggling that they
did to try to do this
led to
either they're doing it or asking the
right questions when those students
leave that classroom that day they will
know how to do that
now contrast that with
the usual approach
i'm going through an example problem
you do this you do this and so on
and if i'm a good lecturer
everything looks clear
one step is following another you do
this you do this you do this okay i
understand that and the students will
leave the class that day and they'll
think oh man that was a great lecture i
really understood that
then they'll go home to try to solve a
similar problem
in a homework assignment and they may
struggle for three and a half hours
on that similar problem because when i'm
doing it in class and they're watching
me do it everything looks clear the hard
parts the easy parts they all look
straightforward but there can be little
points
that look
reasonable but they don't really
understand them
and it's only when they go home to try
it themselves that they realize they
didn't understand some of what i did
and
that's the main if i had to pick one
point
in
what i've been trying to introduce
my colleagues
to in terms of teaching techniques it's
that the more you can get your students
actively engaged in and out of class the
better they're going to learn
and if it's just you lecturing the
entire time
if the students come back the next day
and they don't seem to have been at the
lecture
don't be too surprised
and i could go on for another three and
a half hours here with different points
that i've made but
let's let it go with that one
thank you professor felder so i'm going
to pull at a couple of points which you
raised and i am really resisting the
temptation to pull at all of them
yeah so you mentioned that if a if the
lecturer happens to be a very good one
it can seem to be magically explained in
the classroom only for the students to
be left confounded
uh when they try if they don't even try
to go over it themselves
uh and i think uh a very famous example
of this i i remember having read
somewhere that uh this used to happen in
professor richard feynman's class
because he was a brilliant orator
like a almost like a magician lecturer
so whatever seemed clear and absolutely
perfectly understandable in his class
seemed magically not understandable once
the students tried it themselves
right
then
yeah that's exactly the point that i was
raising again the the theme of this is
that people
learn
meaningfully in only one way
if it's non-trivial
you know if i'm just giving facts that
can be simply memorized and then
repeated i can lecture all right and the
students will just memorize the facts
but if something is conceptually
difficult
which a lot in engineering is
or it's a very tricky calculation or
they're subtle little points that
look obvious but they're not at all
obvious the only way students are going
to learn to do that is not by listening
to me but by trying it themselves
figuring it out or getting feedback then
trying it again
and
that's the point of active learning
no matter how good a lecturer you are
it's not sufficient yeah so uh
so pulling at another point from from
that uh that little condensed version of
your work you have mentioned about the
actual uh logistics of this active
learning where people discuss uh when
the students discuss among themselves in
maybe pairs or triplets
things like this
so
we do have at least in theory a system
of tutorial sessions
uh tutorial sessions
we have it here in the iits and and i'm
sure in some of the other institutes of
india also and these were
uh
at least the purple design of them was
that we we should have something on
these lines
but truth be told what we sometimes end
up doing is that we steal from those
tutorial sessions
to lecture and to actually cover the
syllabus i have myself been guilty of
this
but in the future
yeah so yeah in the few tutorial
sessions that we did have especially for
the second year and third year students
because i try to have this tutorial
sessions religiously for the first year
students uh i never ever sacrificed that
if anything i actually i sacrifice a
lecture or two uh
from uh to go into the tutorial sessions
and this is not something of my own
doing a senior professor actually
suggested to me and incidentally he is
the same professor who had inspired me
to get into teaching and research and
everything back the day so it's a full
cycle
so i have actually uh noticed what you
were what you were pointing out that
when i lecture i can see the happy faces
of the students but when i go into the
tutorial session there are million tips
and bits which
i myself as a lecturer would not have
ever guessed to be a source of confusion
among the students so when i say when i
actually roam around in the class like i
actually roam it on literally roam
around and run around in the class in
the tutorial sessions when i do that
you cannot imagine the kind of doubts
that they come up with and
truth be told yes i can
yes
so so and i'm not ashamed to say this
that during those tutorial sessions i
think over the years over the last five
six years
uh in a cumulative fashion i think i
have ended up learning more from them
than probably they have from me
because there are certain small things
which i would probably never have
emphasized during my lecture sessions
but because i got that that implicit
feedback from the students as they were
working through the problems but i
learned that i needed to focus on those
points during my lectures also
because they seemed pretty obvious to me
but in reality they were not
that is the problem
because once we've learned something and
if we're professors
generally speaking especially after
we've taught a course two or three times
we know that course very well
and it's easy to lose sight of
what is going on in the minds of the
students and what's what seems obvious
to us is not at all obvious to them
absolutely
and that's the point of the act of
learning again you know i keep repeating
this but this is if if you can only get
one message
from everything i'm saying here if
you're uh if you're a student especially
if you're a faculty member if you're
teaching already
that would be the point
get students actively engaged now you
have the tutorial system there
which i'm familiar with
in some cases in the united states
we have courses like that
not all of them usually but
some of them like the introductory
chemical engineering course at my
university north carolina state
university
has
associated with it a tutorial session
and if somebody is teaching
traditionally just lecturing in the
lectures
and then the students go to a tutorial
i'd say probably 90 or more percent of
the learning is taking place in the
tutorials
the lecturer
could just as easily videotape the
lecture and the students can watch it in
the comfort of their own home they won't
learn very much that way either but at
least they'll be more comfortable than
they would be in a traditional classroom
but the the tutorial if the tutorial is
being run correctly which means putting
the students to work rather than just
sitting through more lecture
that's where the learning is going to
take place
and
sometimes
when i'm giving a workshop on teaching
somebody will raise the point that you
did
saying that well i lecture in the
lectures but we have a tutorial session
or a recitation or whatever it's called
all right and so the students are
getting their practice there
and my response to that is uh look
you're spending
45 hours more or less with the students
in the course of a semester
lecturing okay
and the students have the recitations
and they're learning in the recitations
wouldn't it make sense to take at least
some of those
45 hours that we're spending lecturing
to the students and have some learning
taking place there too
and the answer is well of course it
would
in which case we go back to active
learning right now um you can cram as
much information as you want to
in a lecture all right i could cover
probably the whole textbook
in one lecture
50 minutes if i put everything on
powerpoint slides and flash them like
this
during the class and i'll cover the book
will they learn anything no
they won't learn anything because the
human mind is limited in its information
processing capacity the brain can only
take in so much information at a time
which means a very very high percentage
of that information that you're pouring
out like that is never going to be
absorbed by the students so you're
wasting your time you're wasting their
time
if you back off
don't try to present
so much information and imagine that
you've taught it because you haven't
focus on what is the most important
information
that i'm trying to present in this
particular lecture it's not all equally
important
there are a lot of things which if the
students never saw them it wouldn't hurt
them it's not going to be on the exam
you know it's something that we think
well it would be nice to expose them to
it
but just exposure
is relatively worthless as far as
learning is concerned
and so if you're careful to focus on
what is the critical information that
i'm trying to present in this class
today
and you make sure that you present that
information
and let the other stuff go or leave it
for a reading or something of that sort
and then
critical information you give the
students an opportunity to do something
with it to try it and then get feedback
two minutes later
you're going to see a huge difference in
what the students end up knowing
and you're going to see a huge
difference in those recitations
instead of just seeing the blank faces
and the questions that they're now
asking because they never had a chance
to do it before you're going to see
students who understand something from
those lectures and now you can really
put them to work in the in the tutorials
to try more difficult problems to have
interesting discussions and so forth it
makes a huge difference in the nature of
what you're doing
uh as a professional
yeah so in our native tongue we have um
one saying which goes something like
this it's a rough translation uh you eat
less
but you eat well
oh that's good there's another saying uh
it's something i don't remember it
exactly but uh
you know i i hear and see
and i forget
i do
and i understand yes
something to that effect yes and that's
like eating uh
eating less but eating well yeah so
moving on to the students perspective
now
in your extensive experience and you
have also elaborated on this points
in your work when you when you try to
incorporate these kinds of active
learning
you do face a lot of resistance from
certain sections of students
sometimes they are a little bit
frustrated
in more extreme situations they are
almost hostile to your style this this
newfangled style of teaching
where you call upon them to be actually
not just
physically present but also be mentally
awake in class so
how do you deal with such kind of
resistance or hostile behavior
there are several things
um one one thing i'll just
issue a little corrective on is the
notion that this is a newfangled idea
the idea of active learning
um
if you go back to uh the ancient greeks
right uh if you read plato and and hear
about socrates method of teaching
he was using active learning absolutely
socrates was not lecturing right he was
drawing
out the points he wanted to make by
asking
whoever was sitting on the log opposite
him
asking them questions and kind of
guiding them to the understanding that
they were supposed to have in places in
the bible there are references to the
fact that people learn by doing so it's
hardly new
all right it's thousands of years old
this notion
but getting back to your question
yeah
there is resistance
when you introduce active learning to
students who are not accustomed to it
and there's also resistance from
faculty members
the fact i'll get back to the students
in a minute but many faculty members
argue that look i'm the expert here
i'm the one who knows this stuff my job
is to transmit it to the students and
then it's their responsibility to
learn it
and when
when i give workshops to the teachers
which i've done
hundreds of times
i always have to
deal with arguments like that
in both cases when i'm dealing with the
students or when i'm dealing with the
faculty
i turn to
research this is not an unresearched
topic there have been hundreds now
thousands of research studies comparing
the learning that results from straight
lecturing the traditional method of
teaching with the learning that results
from the
effective use of active learning
and the research
data is overwhelming
for almost any learning objective that
you want to look at
conceptual understanding
analytical method
problem solving
everything but just straight
memorization of facts the overwhelming
evidence is that students learn more on
average much more in many cases than
they learn by just having somebody
lecture at them
and i make that argument to uh the
faculty that i'm talking to in the
workshops that that i give
and i make that same argument to the
students
and when i first begin on the first day
of class
i have a little sermon
that i give the students
and it goes something like this all
right let me give you a
preview of how this class is going to
work
i'm going to be
lecturing
but periodically during the lecture i'm
going to stop
and i'm going to give you something to
do
you collectively the students in the
class sometimes i'll ask you to do it
individually and sometimes i'll ask you
to get into small groups and do it
i'll give you a short period of time
could be
15 seconds could be a minute
uh rarely will it ever be more than two
minutes
to do what i'm asking you to do
and i'll describe what i want you to do
and then i'll turn you loose for however
long i'm giving you
and then i'll stop you
and i'll call on some of you to share
what you and your partner came up with
if you get it right i'll congratulate
you
if you get it wrong if i can see
anything rational about what you did
i'll say okay good you're thinking about
this but you also have to consider that
and then i'll call on somebody else to
provide it
and that's how this whole semester is
going to go
throughout the semester this is the
method i'm going to use
the reason i'm doing this my little
sermon goes on is not to make your life
more difficult
to make you do the work that i'm
supposed to be doing by telling you
everything
the reason i'm doing this is because i
have access to
a ton of research
showing that when students are taught in
this manner
they learn more
they learn at a deeper level and they
get higher grades on the examinations
that they're going to take on this
material
that's why i'm going to be doing it this
way
and my sermon concludes i would be happy
to share with any of you who are
interested
the research
that backs me up that says you know
felder's telling you the truth here
now
i will not live long enough for a
student to ever accept that offer
i will
i will never have a student say yes i
want to see that research for myself and
judge its validity and reliable no
they're not going to do that
but the fact that
the fact that i'm i'm telling them i've
got the research i'll share it with you
they will believe me
and they will sit still long enough to
see that i really am telling them the
truth as much as they may not like this
method the first two few times i'm doing
it
they are ending up learning more and
they'll realize this and i've also got
research proving that
people have studied and written papers
on students resistance to active
learning
and what they find is if it's done right
and there are right and wrong ways to do
active learning and uh i've written
quite a bit about that too in the book
that you mentioned and in papers
but the research shows that the
resistance may be high at first and then
in a matter of a week or two weeks at
most
of active learning the resistance
generally disappears
all right it's not a problem anymore
the other thing that the research shows
is that once the students have done
active learning in one course
there's no more resistance ever next
course that they get in if the
instructor is doing active learning
and says for on the first day of class
okay get into groups now the students
just do it oh okay this again and uh
and they're fine with it so there is
some initial resistance
to active learning but if you're doing
active learning correctly and if you let
the students know here's what i'm doing
here's why i'm doing it the resistance
just pretty much disappears as a problem
so uh that last point you made i think
it's a fine segue to my next question to
you uh which i had uh i had a little
discussion with you over email and i was
completely in the dark about this so we
have different kinds of students right
uh we have introverted students
extroverted students and any anything in
between
so i personally i i think i was a bit of
an introvert
i found it difficult to talk with
anybody and everybody
so
my feeling was that if a professor back
in let's say 2004-2005
would have
suddenly declared on the first day of
class that from today onwards we are
going to do active learning in this
course
i would have been
a little bit scared to put it mildly
uh the very the very fact that uh that i
had left home for the first time in my
life left the productive environments of
my school
uh and here i was all alone in a new
institute living in a hostel with my
mates
everything was new the only last last
semblance of familiarity was in the was
in the lecture room where the teacher
would come and very authoritatively
teach me
if that also fell away now i would be in
shutters that was my feeling so i told
you that wouldn't be perhaps better if
for the sake of the introverted students
uh selfishly speaking
that we perhaps introduce active
learning a little bit later
so so could you please recount for the
sake of i'm sure there will be other
introverted students will be listening
to this for their benefit what you told
me
sure
well the short answer to your question
is no
would not be better to delay
the most important thing to me as a
teacher
is not making all my students happy
the most important thing to me as a
teacher is learning
i want my students to learn the material
i'm teaching them it's
very important to me that they learn and
if i have a technique which is going to
promote learning
help them learn better better prepare
them for the examinations that i'm going
to be giving them
then i want to take full advantage of
that technique
and then i'll just
bounce back to my previous answer
it does um
worry you if you're an introvert you're
initially probably going to resist
uh active learning to some extent
but the research on active learning that
i quoted before was looking at the
students as a body introverts and
extroverts alike
and what it found is that the resistance
of both the introverts and the
extroverts the initial resistance of the
introverts may be a little bit greater
but it's going to go away fairly quickly
if you're doing active learning
correctly and the students are going to
learn more
the other thing is
you're i suspect exaggerating
how bad you would feel as an introvert
in finding yourselves being put into
this
where it would really be scary is if i'm
making you get up and talk in front of
the entire class
as even introverts
are not all that uncomfortable talking
to one or
at most two other people in a small
group for two minutes
that's not going to terrify you
no matter how strong an introvert you
are
and i can tell you
you know i may not be acting like an
introvert now but trust me i am one
and i'm a very strong introvert in real
life
the reason i may not seem like one now
is because i'm a teacher
and what i found is that to be an
effective teacher i can't just
be like that i've got to get out there
in front of the students be connecting
with them transmitting information to
them
listening to them if they have questions
and so even though i am an introvert in
real life i have to at least pretend to
be an extrovert to be effective as a
teacher but if you're a student and a
strong introvert
it's not going to be as terrifying as
you're afraid of
to find yourself being asked to do
active learning the other thing i'll
briefly tell you about is i did a
research study
i don't know 20 years ago or so
in which i followed
a class in a chemical engineering class
through the curriculum
teaching them one
core course one required course
a semester for five consecutive
semesters
using all of the techniques that uh
most of the techniques i talk about in
the book including active learning
and i surveyed those students
the object of the research study was to
find out what will happen if you use
these techniques repeatedly usually a
student might see active learning in one
class and then never see it again
my question was what will happen if they
keep seeing it would the benefits
of
this technique shown by the research be
even greater if it's reinforced
and i did that and i published quite a
few papers on it but one of the
interesting things is i surveyed the
students in every semester asking them
how do you feel about these little
activities that we're doing in class do
you think they're helping your learning
do you think they're hindering your
learning or
it doesn't make much difference i can
take them or leave them
and what i found is that in that first
semester that i taught and i asked the
students this question
right at the very beginning in the first
week of the course
i got a pretty good distribution but the
introverts because i also had a way of
determining who was introvert and who
was extrovert the introverts were more
resistant more of them didn't like
these small groups than the extroverts
who thought oh this is great i love
talking to people and this gives me a
chance to do it
but what i found was that
later in the semester six weeks into the
semester i asked the same question
and
the resistance
from everybody dropped considerably
and by the end of the sequence of
courses after they've been doing this
for a couple of years the introverts
actually preferred the group activities
to just lecturing to a greater extent
than the extroverts did and my theory
about that is that the introverts
realized that if they had been left
given the choice
many of them would have said no i don't
want to do that i want to work by myself
and so forth but after they had done it
for
three semesters or so
realized that
they were learning
in these activities in a way that they
had never before learned
and so they expressed an even stronger
preference for active learning than the
extroverts did that both groups really
liked it but the introverts even more
than the extroverts
so uh
thank you for pointing that out in in
such a nice elaborate way uh so
regarding what i felt during my first
year and what happened later on i just
uh saved for the benefit of the students
who may be in a similar position as mine
so in my first year i was an introvert i
stayed that way
and i saw all around me students who
would bunch up in groups study together
so although there was no active learning
that was being actually done
during the classes but since we are in a
residential campus uh many of the
students actually chose some sort of
active learning in their own way and
even though i stayed with my books much
longer than they did
they did better than me
so so i'm a professor of mechanical
engineering now uh and people think that
i have been and like an over-the-top
excellent student all the while it's not
true
okay i didn't do as well i as i should
have considered the considering the fact
that i was with my books all the time i
didn't do as well as i should have in my
first year but in my second year uh i i
just took a cue from some of my friends
and maybe opened up just a little bit
and i and i was very privileged to have
a very good set of friends in my
department so when i when i roamed
around
with them studied with them just a
little bit more than my first year
my academic performance simply increased
like a huge it took a huge step forward
so
there was not much difference in the
teaching style so to speak from first
year to second year but it was a change
in my attitude of me just trying to
consciously trying to open up a little
bit that really helped me out a lot
so
i think if we can do it from our own uh
uh our own initiative as students if the
professor's input is there in terms of
the active
uh learning and this and the learning
center teaching it could be a huge huge
boost to
uh the whole spectrum of students so i i
really believe that from an from an
anecdotal perspective also
right
now let me
let me add something to what you just
said because what you just said is uh
absolutely correct i mean you could see
the benefit
of working with other people whether it
was out of class or whether it was in
class you could see it the fact of the
matter is though for most
people who go into the teaching
profession no matter where you are in
united states in india anywhere else
you've got to recognize that most of
your students probably are not like you
you are one of those who finished
undergraduate education went on
got a doctorate
uh and went to teach at a first rate
university
you're teaching at an iit
which are some of the best universities
in the world
and you don't get into an iit
unless you're up here generally speaking
those really good students
they're going to learn
with your help without your help
despite you
if necessary
most
engineering students
don't
go on and get phds most of them don't go
to iits
right and there is a huge dropout rate i
know you know this it's common knowledge
people drop like flies out of general
engineering programs
and if i'm a teacher and teaching at one
of those universities
i feel an obligation to do everything i
can
everything i've learned about what makes
teaching effective to try to help these
students who basically have the
capability of learning
but
not necessarily all by themselves i've
got to use every effective teaching
technique i know
to make those students who have the
basic ability to learn this stuff to
help them learn it
and so that's another argument for using
active learning
some students again will resist it
but more of them are going to learn
and succeed
and graduate get their degrees if i use
these learner center techniques
than if i just lectured and so i
consider that i have an ethical and
moral obligation to do the best teaching
i know how to do to try to help those
students who have the potential to do it
succeed
so thank you professor felder very much
so uh i know this little discussion that
you just had wasn't part of our original
plan of questions and answers
but
really thank you very much for pointing
this out because a lot of the student
viewers who
take a look at my views
at my videos
they are not from the iits they are not
from the nits at the national institutes
of technology they are from uh some
other uh colleges where they have
certain challenges uh because of the
circumstances because of the quality of
teaching overall uh and and different
other things like like a million other
things
so
it's really really uh
it's going to be
i think inspirational for many of them
when they hear your words
and
more than that i think if uh if anyone
is listening uh from among our faculty
colleagues from those institutes it is
my humble request to you uh to perhaps
give this
active
learning the learning center teaching a
try uh it has been proven through
research there's a lot of support for it
and as scientists and engineers we
should uh believe the research
yeah and let me just add
let me just add one thing to that advice
given which is excellent advice
don't just go into class
uh this coming monday
and
start using active learning
all right
because i i've emphasized in everything
i've been saying now
that
lots and lots of research shows
that active learning done effectively
leads to greater learning but that done
effectively is very important there are
some
ineffective ways of doing active
learning and if you just jump in and
start putting students to work in groups
without first learning a little bit
about what are the what are the pitfalls
what
should you not do
when you're starting on this technique
you could uh
not see the results that you're looking
for
so before you launch into it spend a
little time researching it do what we've
all been trained to do
is find out something about it now i
think uh i think the book that i wrote
with my colleague rebecca brent
is a good source of information but
there are many good teaching books
and
papers on these techniques find out a
little bit about what are the pitfalls
what are the mistakes to avoid
like for instance let me just give you
one
uh you're going to do active learning
and so you um
you come into class
or
the uh the tutorial
and you say okay everybody i want you to
get into groups of uh
two or three
and i want you to solve this problem
i'll give you 20 minutes to do it
go
bad
right
why is that a bad technique
one is uh because
two things can happen
when you do that and you give them 20
minutes the problem with that is 20
minutes is much too long for an active
learning exercise
some of the little groups in class
of the
top students
will be able to solve it in four minutes
and now they're wasting 16 valuable
minutes of class time talking about the
football game or whatever it is they're
doing
and class time is very valuable both in
a tutorial and in a lecture session
and you don't want 16 minutes to just be
spent idly conversing because you
finished with the problem
other groups maybe the students are not
quite as good
will struggle for the entire 20 minutes
trying to figure this thing out
and they won't be able to do it
that is also a supreme waste of class
time
not much learning is going on after the
first two or three minutes of that
struggle
and so what's really important in active
learning is to keep the activities short
and focused
so you don't say take 20 minutes and
solve this problem
what you say is
i want you to take one minute
see how far you can get in getting this
problem solution started
go
and now again
you stop them after a minute you're
getting answers from them what they did
and you're filling in anything that they
miss
and then if the next part of the problem
is totally straightforward you can just
quickly lecture through it simple
algebra you know they know how to do
that and then you get to the next
difficult or challenging part and maybe
now it's two minutes okay now go back
see how far you can get in solving this
part of the problem that back and forth
like that is what makes active learning
work what makes it effective and those
brief struggles
are the most important part of it
so
research active learning a little bit
before you do it and
other techniques that we talk that we
can talk about here
it's the same thing don't just do it
find out a little bit about how and how
not to do it then get started you
probably won't get it right on the first
day you try it
like everything else you do it takes
practice but it won't take you too long
before you really start to become
effective at it
yeah so uh pulling on that
point which you mentioned regarding uh
if you read up a little bit of active
learning you will learn uh quite a few
things
uh but then those try don't just try to
implement all of them next monday
uh
and i think you mentioned this over
email that it's not a good idea to
expect yourself to undergo a personality
transplant
to
to just engage in active learning we are
faculty members but we are also
fundamentally human beings flesh and
blood uh we have our own personality
limitations so
probably keep that in mind also
yeah um when uh when i give the workshop
the teaching workshops the faculty
uh they generally last a day a day and a
half
uh two days
um
and sometimes a couple of hours
but at the end of one of the long
workshops like a two-day workshop
my
final speech
before i let them all go
uh it goes like this
okay look in the last two days
i've presented you with
187 different teaching techniques
with a strong recommendation for all of
them that this will help your students
learning
then i say what you just said given i
said
the message i'm giving you is not
do all 187 of them starting next monday
that's a prescription for failure
right
you can't do
to you'll be doing too many new things
all at once
you won't be confident in your ability
to do this you're going to start getting
resistance from some of the students and
if you try to do all that new stuff
you're going to get a lot of resistance
from the students
and you're going to decide after that
experience i'm never going to want to do
this again i'm going to go back to
lecturing
the message i'm giving you is
take
one or two of those 187 techniques
and try
those
and give them a fair try don't just try
active learning once and the student
used to tell the students to get into
groups and do something and they just
look at you like you must be kidding
it's going to take some getting used to
for both them and for you so try it a
few times so that the students start
becoming accustomed to it
and if it's working keep doing it if
it's not working after you've given it a
fair try then stop doing it next
semester
next course you teach
go back and pick another one or two
techniques try them if they work keep
doing them if they don't then stop doing
them and if you do this i'll give you a
guarantee
your teaching is just going to start
getting better
and it's going to keep getting better
because if a technique is not making
your teaching better you're not going to
keep doing it
and so the one thing you can guarantee
if you do this is the course you teach
this semester
is going to be better
than the same course when you taught it
last semester or last year
and you're going to steadily increase as
you keep adding more and more of these
techniques and that's all you need to do
you're never going to reach perfection
right
but if you make steady progress your
courses are getting better and better
the students are learning more and more
you win
that's all you need to do
and that's all you have to worry about
doing right
we strive for our personal best every
time
yes
and our personal best if we keep
striving will keep getting better
exactly
all right so uh
so this is another uh thing on the
positive side uh let me go back to being
a little bit negative um
so we know for a fact that sometimes
because of the circumstances because of
administrative constraints or
there are million other things which may
be hindering
professors from taking up this active
learning
at least on mass
now
for students of such institutes is it
perhaps
is there any hope for them to perhaps
engage in some sort of active learning
so
it may be a little bit of a contentious
question but
if you could just discuss this
sure and you've already answered that
question for yourself given
when you described your introversion
and your fear of active learning and
then you discovered that
studying with other students outside
class
uh helped you
you know it helped your learning
absolutely
you were doing active learning
right the difference is you were doing
it on your own you were doing it on your
own you were working with other students
sharing ideas uh
figuring out things together and this
one doesn't see it but that one figures
it out and now you both know it that's
exactly what active learning does and
one thing that you can do is encourage
your students to do that
right if you're teaching this course
active learning
i want as much learning as possible to
take place so i want to use my class
as a time when the students are working
together but that doesn't mean they
don't carry it outside class and if
they're taking from a teacher who
doesn't use active learning it becomes
all the more important for them to get
into these small groups and teach each
other outside class
and i think it helps matters a lot even
if there is one teacher who is somehow
able to introduce this entire aspect of
active learning because once the
students are exposed to it even if their
other teachers are not doing it perhaps
they can
carry over those learnings those styles
of learning to other courses also on
their
right
all i can say in response to that is uh
i completely agree
uh i couldn't put it better myself yeah
so
i'd like to uh raise one very important
point which you have mentioned yourself
during our email communications
uh it is that
what does cognitive science tell us
about how stem students are students of
science technology engineering and
mathematics
should study for exams how it hurts them
and what's the best way to study
okay
one thing and and this is relatively uh
recent that this has gotten into the
literature but the typical way that most
stem students study is probably the
worst way
that they can study
here's the here's
the usual
preparation for examinations
the student
looks over
old tests
and
looks at the answers the solutions that
were
put up on the board outside the
classroom
and just reads over them
and says oh okay i do this i do this i
do this oh that's clear i understand
that and it says this next problem i do
this this and this and they go through
the old exams like that they look at
solutions to homework problems that
they've done in the past
and they
maybe
re-read the textbook
uh just looking through it again
why is that a bad technique
because what cognitive science has found
and
this is a little bit of a tangent
but what is learning mean what is
learning
its definition
cognitively is taking in information
and storing it
in long-term memory in your brain
and then subsequently retrieving it when
you need it like on the exam
and what the cognitive scientists have
found
is that
retrieval is not
automatic
the fact that something is in your
long-term memory it'll stay there
forever but that doesn't mean you can
bring it back out when you need it like
on the exam
and what the scientists have found is
that what facilitates retrieval
subsequent retrieval is previous
retrieval
when i first learned something when i
first get it into my long-term memory
if
i try to remember it in a week the
chances are if i've only seen it once
the chances are good that i won't
remember it
right and if
i learn it in class and i don't see it
again until the exam six weeks later the
chances are very good that i won't be
able to retrieve it
it's in there but i can't get it back
out to put it on the exam so what
facilitates subsequent retrieval
it's prior retrieval the more you
retrieve a piece of information
the easier it's going to be to retrieve
it subsequently like on the
exam and so what's the problem with that
traditional method of studying which is
really
old solutions and things like that
you're not retrieving it when you do
that you're just casting your eyes over
it
and expecting something useful to happen
which it probably won't
so that's not a good way to study what
is a good way to study it's to retrieve
the information force yourself to
retrieve the information
like here's an old problem on an exam or
here's a problem out of the textbook or
out of a homework assignment
if i just look at the solution it's not
going to help me
what i need to do is try to solve that
problem by myself without looking
at anything just work work it out myself
if i can do it that means i've retrieved
it that means the chances are good i'll
be able to retrieve it again or
something similar to it on the exam
if i try retrieving it solving the
problem by myself without looking back
at anything chances are good i'll get
stuck all right
what i do then is i go back now and look
at the solution
and see where i got stuck
and see how i would proceed from there
then i put the problem away
and i go on to look at something another
problem that i'm going to try to solve
then an hour later or a day later
or two days later i go back and i try to
solve that problem again without looking
at anything
now the chances are much much better
than i'm going to be able to do it
and if i study if i test myself like
this
and try to solve it without looking back
at anything
i'm going to be ready for that exam and
the chances are much much better that
i'm going to get a good grade on it than
if i just use the usual method of
re-reading things
if there's factual information
uh definitions that i've got to memorize
or here's a diagram this is a
biology class and here's a diagram of
the human body with all of the different
parts labeled
the way i'm going to study for that
if i'm a traditional student studying is
i'll look at that diagram again okay
that's the liver that's the spleen and
so on and then i'll put it away and go
on to something else i haven't retrieved
the information from my long-term memory
i've just looked at it again
so now what i do is i make flash cards
for myself
and i test myself on them
or i'll put the diagram there without
any of the labels on it and i'll try to
put in the labels myself
and again i'm retrieving it from
long-term memory i keep doing that if i
as much as i need to and again now i'm
going to do better on the test than i
would if i studied in the traditional
way
students don't know that that's
relatively new information but they can
help themselves tremendously by just
getting that little information about
how the brain works into their long-term
memory
so uh professor felder what you just
mentioned has actually triggered some
old memories
uh of what i did during my fourth year
so what happened was that by the time i
was in my fourth year
i was completely familiar with the
system here
and i had grown quite confident
so confident even that i got into some
bad habits of studying
so by this time i was no longer an
introvert at least i had gotten over the
issues associated with it
now
what happened was that
the way that i started studying was that
before the exams maybe one week before
the exams i used to sit down with the
books and the notes and somehow used to
swallow them home
now
i ended up getting very good grades
but what happened was that later on some
of these coursework material
actually came
i mean
i had to use them during my phd work
and when i was
trying to apply those things i realized
that basically
i did not remember or or more
importantly i had not really understood
what i had studied and gotten
excellent grades on
so this retrieval problem and not just
retrieval like fundamentally
understanding something
is
completely different from just getting a
good grade in an examination
contrasted to this what i probably
studied in my second year especially in
my fourth semester there was one course
and i did not do any similar course to
that later on but still somehow i i
remember doing
i remember some of the things because
i struggled through
through the problem sheets so much
during the course all throughout the
semester
the key
the key to
active learning
is that or
studying for an examination and you're
trying to solve these problems
uh for uh for yourself without looking
at the solutions it's difficult but it's
a desirable difficulty because that's
struggling
is what's going to lead to the
subsequent learning and understanding to
the point where you're able to
do something similar on the exams
and so
uh trying to make everything easy now
it's easy to reread things yeah like old
problem solutions you just do it cast
your eyes over it and imagine you're
doing something useful which you're
probably not
but those struggles that you just
described that you were having when you
were studying for these uh difficult
examinations were what led to your
subsequent good performance and your
high grades on the tests and on the in
the courses
right
okay uh
felder um
i i want to bring up a point which may
not be of that much use to our
undergraduate students but i think uh
there are quite a few phd students who
do view my channel and some post doc
students also post doctoral researchers
and some faculty members some early
career faculty members so for their sake
i would like you to kindly touch upon
that eternal tension between
investing time or dividing time between
teaching and research
okay
um so from the point of view
of faculty members if you're teaching at
a institution
that has a strong research expectation
um
and i i'm not
that familiar with the system in india
whether you have the same system for
promotion and tenure
uh
there that that we have here so at the
iits uh we have a system which is
heavily uh i mean which heavily rewards
research achievements
if you are bad at teaching
uh it may create problems
but it will probably not absolutely
hinder your growth
but if you're bad at research then
bye-bye get here
okay we have exactly the same system
in the united states as you just
described in india
and so this is in the iits there are
certain institutes uh
very good institutes like uh top notch
institutes in terms of undergraduate
training they they encourage people to
invest a lot of time on teaching there
are institutes like that
all right let me
answer that question by describing a
little bit about my career
so i started uh
somewhere in the late jurassic period is
when i first began
and so i'm there at north carolina state
university which is a a top-notch
university with a very high research
expectation it's exactly the way you
just described the iits
if you they really expect you to excel
in research to get the
the grants to write the papers in the
top journals and so forth and you could
be in trouble if you're not able to do
that in terms of
remaining a faculty member at that
institution and they also want you to be
a good teacher
right
but
if you're doing all the research very
well and you're doing an adequate job of
teaching they're not uh marching to the
dean demanding your removal for instance
because your teaching is so bad you'll
probably do fine
so what i discovered i had no training
in teaching beforehand like
like everyone else
and um i was considered a decent
lecturer but i was making a lot of
mistakes
all right the students liked my lectures
but i was getting fairly low grades on
the exams from my students
and so clearly i wasn't doing the kind
of teaching job that i would have liked
to do
i learned by trial and error as we do i
got better at teaching
and i started maybe 10 years into my
career discovering that there was such a
thing as learner-centered teaching and
some of the act of learning some of
these other things
but i still played the
did the research and kept that as a top
priority for myself
and i moved up the academic ladder i got
promoted from assistant professor to
associate then from associate professor
to
full professor and i even got a name
professor and i was doing the research
and and
doing it well i was succeeding at it i
was getting the grants i was publishing
the papers
about 10 to 15 years into my career
i
took stock of where i was in my career
and i
admitted to myself finally i'd sort of
known it all along but
i finally admitted to myself that i
liked the research i enjoyed doing the
research and i was succeeding at it i
loved the teaching
nothing gave me as much satisfaction
in the research that i was doing
as i got from really
the teaching going well
to see light bulbs going on over
students as they grasped
difficult concepts and they did well
they started off maybe getting a low
grade on the first exam but they just
kept getting better and better as they
were learning
and that gave me more satisfaction than
anything i was doing in research
and i was now a full professor
and if my colleagues or my department
had didn't like what i was doing
uh the worst that they could do to me
was and i mean my one half of one
percent merit raise
and i could live with that
and so at that point
i stopped
doing technical research
i focused on my teaching and i was also
still doing research but it was research
on education
research on teaching and learning
and i had a wonderful satisfying happy
career for the rest of my career
now if i had tried to do that in my
first year
or in my first three years switching
away from the technical research
focusing entirely on teaching
it would not have ended well
so you've got to be aware of what is the
incentive and reward system at your
university if you're teaching
if research is what's rewarded and
teaching is
in second place still do what you can
there's a lot of simple things you can
do in teaching
that can have a big impact on the
students but if something is going to
require a huge investment of your time
to adopt
then maybe you want to hold off on that
stick with the simple but effective
teaching methods and focus on your
research as much as you need to
and then if you get tenure
to the point where you have a secure
position at the university now it's up
to you
if you want to continue focusing on your
research and just do an adequate job of
teaching fine do that
if you want to change your priority
and focus more on
on your teaching
less on the technical research
at that point you can do that if you
want to maintain a good balance
which is probably the best option for
most faculty members then you do that it
becomes up to you but as long as it's
not entirely under your control
you've got to work within the system
that you're working in
thank you professor felder so so i'll
try to remember that as a very personal
advice also
uh so when you mentioned about the the
very simple and effective things one can
do
uh
when i was going through your book i
noticed something as simple uh but very
critical
as learning objectives specifying the
learning objectives at the outset
so could you perhaps
mention that we do not have to sacrifice
anything of our from our research to do
that in our coursework okay so let's
uh let's define what a learning
objective is
let's let's start by saying what a
learning objective is not
a learning objective is not a statement
of here's what i'm going to teach you
a learning objective is not even a
statement of
here's what i want you to learn
so what is a learning objective
a learning objective is a statement of
if i'm successful at teaching you
what i want you to learn
here's what you should be able to do
to demonstrate that you've learned it
here are the kinds of problems that i
expect you to be able to solve
here are the kinds of things i expect
you to be able to do in a in a
laboratory
and so on so it's a statement of here
are the things that students should be
able to do to demonstrate that they have
gained the knowledge mastered the skills
that i'm trying to impart to them in
this course
and once you start formulating those
it changes everything about your
teaching
once you've formulated your learning
objectives you use them to dictate
everything you're doing in the course
what you cover in class
what you put on the assignments the
homework assignments what you put on the
exams the kinds of activities that you
do during class in active learning
everything about that course
follows from the learning objectives
and what that does is you end up
teaching a really coherent course
you don't do this sort of thing where
you teach this
and you do something else uh on the
homework assignments and then you put
things on exams which are different from
what you did during the class and so
forth everything is pointing
to the same
uh knowledge and skills
and
it sounds straightforward but it changes
teaching
and learning
completely when you use learning
objectives to dictate
everything you're doing in that course
and that's something that most faculty
members who aren't familiar with the
literature and with these
learner-centered methods uh don't do
you know most professors write their
syllabus we're going to cover this this
this this and this and then they're done
and that leads to things like teaching
this and then testing on something else
which is utterly pointless but if you're
using learning objectives correctly that
doesn't happen the whole course is
coherent
and so if i were naming two things
of everything we cover in the workshop
and everything we cover in that book
that i would say if you don't do
anything else we're recommending
do
this
one
active learning and two
the formulation and systematic use of
learning objectives to dictate
everything that goes on in that course
and that will get you a long way toward
where
you want to go to make your teaching as
effective as it possibly can be
thank you professor felder from the
point of learning objectives on how to
write them down
i was actually a little bit surprised
to see you very clearly mentioning not
to use words like to understand this and
that to appreciate this and that so
those are no goals that that's not
really a learning objective right yeah i
have been personally guilty of
statements like that in my learning
objectives but i will correct them
you and everyone else
yeah all right so what's wrong with um
we we have uh the what we call the four
forbidden words
words that should not appear in the
learning
objectives
the students will know this
will learn this
will
appreciate this or will understand this
what's wrong with those words
what's wrong with them is that they're
not observable
i cannot see a student understanding
something
i would never write an exam which says
to the students problem three understand
this
would be meaningless
in order to know whether or not let me
give you a
concrete example in the introductory
chemical engineering course
that i teach and for which i wrote the
textbook that a
lot of people use
one of the things that we cover is the
ideal gas equation of state familiarly
called the ideal gas law pv equals nrt
all right so i could tell you that in
this course that i'm teaching
one of my uh one of my objectives one of
my goals is for my students to
understand the ideal gas equation
you could then turn around and tell me
well okay that seems like a worthwhile
goal how would you know whether or not
they do
and there are several things i might
answer in response to that i might say
well
i'll give them a
temperature and a pressure and ask them
to calculate the volume of the gas or
i'll give them
conditions of a gas
temperature and pressure
and i'll ask them for this combination
of
tnp
would the ideal gas law be a good
approximation
explain
or i might say well i'll ask the
students to derive the ideal gas
equation of state
right from the kinetic theory of gases
whatever i tell you
you would then tell me good those are
your learning objectives for the general
goal of
understanding the ideal gas equation the
only way i can know whether or not a
student understands something
is to ask them to do something that
requires that understanding and then i
can look at what they do it's observable
and i can judge do they understand the
ideal gas law or not did they do that
correctly or not
and so the key
characteristic of the learning
objectives is that it has to be
observable
it has to be something you can either
see the students doing
or see the results of the student having
done it
the other characteristic
uh required characteristic of the
learning objectives is that it must be
clear to the students yes
when a student reads one of my learning
objectives they can say
all right the learning objective is for
me to
um
derive the equation of state
do i know how to do that
if i do
good i'll go on to the next objective
and see if i know how to do that one
if i don't if i'm not sure how to derive
that equation that says i better go back
in there and learn it
because clearly i'm going to need to
know how to do i i might need to know
how to do that on the exam that's coming
up
so
observable learning objectives give
students the information that they need
to know is this something i need to
study or i don't need to worry about it
and for that reason it must be clear to
the student if i give an objective to
the student and the student says what
does that mean
clearly it's not going to help anyone
but if my objectives are observable it's
something that the instructor can see
that the student either knows or doesn't
know how to do and it's clear to the
student
then
it's a good objective
and now if a student says i don't
understand that objective on the study
guide
now it's up to me to
change the statement of the objective to
something that the students will all
know yeah i know how to do that or
i don't know how to do that and i better
find out
thank you
correctly if i'm wrong so this sounds uh
this kind of a philosophy behind
formulating the learning objectives it
seems to
echo
professor carl popper's theory of
falsifiability uh
i don't know if uh if i'm
if i'm
remembering it correctly so he said that
a theory can be good or great depending
on whether you can actually falsify it
through experiments
so
yeah no that's good
that's a beautiful analogy
uh it can be falsified yeah that's true
of a theory
and uh
the the key is clarity right if if a
theory cannot be falsified
you know you can't prove that it's wrong
um
you also can't prove that it's right
under those circumstances and
and it's not much
it's not much good to anybody a learning
objective
is only
valuable
if it gives the professor
the basis for judging whether or not a
student has
learned something whether it's been
effective teaching
and it gives the student
guidance in
knowing what they need to study
without observability and clarity
it's it's not a worthwhile it's not a
useful objective
all right
so uh
we are coming to the last question now
of this discussion
um
so this is uh somewhat of an
um
an idealistic question maybe a little
bit hopeful uh
a bit too optimistic maybe but uh
all throughout these last two years
during the during the pandemic years
when we have been
taking up
uh
measures to impart online education
at least some of us who have spent
a lot of effort and time and i know i
have actually sacrificed time from my
own research on teaching this because i
was completely at my wit's end on how to
do this i didn't know anything about
online teaching i
i literally started learning about
online teaching uh maybe from the month
of april 2020 and really really started
learning it about uh about how to handle
anything
even even even the technological things
how to handle it
starting from maybe july or august 2020
uh as a bit of a late starter in this
but eventually i think
i managed to do an honest job of it
my students will be the best judges of
it
but in the process i have also learned
some things which were missing from my
offline teaching also
so this
it's not just the the infusion of
technology in our teaching but through
the infusion of teaching
technology in our teaching certain bits
which are actually missing in the whole
philosophy of how we talk
so
maybe in this critical juncture of
history when we are going back to
offline classes
to some semblance of normalcy that we
had before the pandemic
do you think it would be
a good idea to
maybe even if gradually
think of
infusing very consciously not and not as
a forceful measure our technology
enhanced active learning
well i'm looking for a yes from you
you got it oh and that's a that's a
critically important question
and it's one that uh practically all of
this profession have been wrestling with
now for two years you know about the
time you started
worrying about active learning april of
2020 is when i and most of my colleagues
started worrying about it
and
we
were gradually moving up the learning
curve the way we learned how to teach
offline in the traditional mode you
didn't start out by doing it well
you started out by making a lot of
mistakes and learning from them and
gradually getting better and better the
same thing is true of uh online
education
i'll say a couple of things about that
one i consider two things two aspects of
teaching
to be critically important
in online education
you have any
idea of what those two things might be
i've given hints about it in this
presentation
okay no one
one
learning objectives oh
two
active learning
teaching is teaching
whether you're doing it the way we're
communicating now to each other or
whether you're doing it in a traditional
live classroom
or whether it's a hybrid you're doing
some of this and some of that
there are advantages to one of these
environments
and disadvantages and conversely for the
other environment there are some things
that you can do better online
than you can in an additional
mode
let's just consider lecture all right
straight lecture i get up and give a
lecture in a class and i'm traditional
i'm talking at the students for 50
minutes or 75 minutes and they're
listening and maybe they're asking
questions maybe they're just sitting
there passively receiving information
maybe they're not even passively
receiving information
they're focusing more on the cell phone
which is in their lap that they're busy
texting a friend or whatever may be
going on all right so that's the
traditional approach
the online approach is now instead of
giving a lecture
in a classroom to students i videotape
the lecture
all right and the students
watch the taped lecture in the comfort
of their uh their own home or dormitory
room or wherever there is
i'm going to argue that the
not much learning is going to happen
either way
right because it's a straight lecture
there's no active involvement there's no
desirable difficulty it's just passive
reception of information
but i'm guessing that the online
approach is going to be more effective
than the traditional lecture approach
why because the student has some control
in the online environment
if i say something which is
incomprehensible to the student just
flies right past them they can stop
rewind play it again
and they can do that as many times as
they need to until
it either becomes clear to them or they
have a question that they can formulate
and send to the professor in whatever
mode of communication they have or if
the professor is having office hours
online then the student can bring that
question to the professor
whereas in a lecture
straight lecture the professor is just
talking the information just flies by
and if it's not understood the student
cannot ask the professor to stop and
rewind
and
repeat it again
there are some advantages to
the live class i mean in a live class
the student can raise their hand
and stop me and ask a question although
if i'm looking at 150 students in this
class very few students would do that
all right um
but if it's if they're watching it on uh
on a day on a videotape they can go back
and forth as often as they want so
there's some things you can do better
online some things you can do better
the optimal approach is hybrid
you do online the things you do that are
best done online you do face to face the
things that are best done that way and
you've got the best of all possible
worlds
now active learning
learning objectives it doesn't matter
whether it's online or face-to-face you
just formulate your learning objectives
use them to design your assignments and
exams and so forth
active learning it's not quite as
obvious how to do it
online
but there are ways to do it if it's a
synchronous class you have these
breakout rooms you can do the same thing
you could do in a face-to-face class
stop the lecture
get the students into small groups using
breakout rooms or whatever it is and and
do active learning
if it's asynchronous
it's not quite as obvious how you would
do it but you can organize students in
your asynchronous class into study
groups all right have them communicate
get online with each other and
work out problems in their group
and again
you can do some things better this way
something's better that way
if you learn the technology if you learn
how to get students actively engaged and
in the last year i've co-authored two
papers on exactly that
one of them in advances in engineering
education the other one in the
international journal of engineering
education on getting students getting
active engagement online
if you take the time to learn some of
those techniques read the papers
and then start putting it to work the
same way you've not always done in your
face-to-face class
you're going to be doing very good
teaching in in either environment
thank you professor felder so i think
well what you have suggested uh we can
make it work even during the offline
classes so hopefully god willing from
next autumn semester or fall semester uh
we are going to go back to our actual
classes uh everyone
hopefully big hope um
so yeah
so i think even if we do lecture uh
i think it would be a good idea to
anyway uh
record some some of the more important
parts of the lecture and share them with
the students because there is always
this facility of pausing maybe slowing
down thinking and then uh at least i
personally like this way for the few
courses that we have had those video
lectures uh it was absolutely fabulous
yeah that's beautiful yeah i have one
suggestion i have one suggestion for you
do that
in the next course you teach do exactly
that
introduce online supplements to whatever
you're doing in the traditional
classroom
and do it enough that you feel confident
you've got a handle on it
that you're doing it reasonably well
that it's helping the students
and when you get to that point write a
paper about it
and share that knowledge with the rest
of us on faculties so that they can take
advantage of your
of your insight and your experience in
doing this
that's a wonderful idea why didn't i
think of it
all right so i think we are at an end
let me just check if i've missed any
important points i think i have not uh i
have a million other personal questions
to go through i i wish i could borrow
your brain for an entire day uh but i
think i think we are yeah we have uh we
have covered what we plan to cover uh
and has been wonderful absolutely
like fabulously wonderful talking to you
and i really hope that
the few teachers who do view my channel
will find some value and meaning in it
but more importantly my my eternal wish
is that
there'll be some kid out there who will
feel sufficiently motivated to take up
this beautiful job that we have
i share that wish completely with you
and thank you for this opportunity
thank you